Vale, genial. No estaba grabando todo
esto. Vale,
estupendo.
Vale, el tema tres, los tipos de red,
¿vale? Los protocolos básicos
ante CPIP.
Vale,
vale. Los lo que debemos de saber es que
TCP es un conjunto de protocolos que
permiten la comunicación
en redes e internet, aunque no siguen
exactamente el modelo OSI.
Vale, entonces, vale, la arquitectura de
TCP no se fija en nivel dos de OSI, lo
asume en lo que llaman nivel de red,
pero las instalaciones habituales de
redes TCIP solucionan, o sea, utilizan
redes el nivel dos de OSI.
El nivel
de enlace asegura una conexión libre de
rodes entre dos ordenadores de la misma
red. fundamentalmente organizada,
organiza los bizamas
y los pasa a la capa física para que
sean transmitidos al receptor a través
del medio de transmisión.
Distinguir dos funciones
en esta capa.
Como en muchas redes de área local, los
canales están compartidos por muchos
nodos.
¿Cómo saber que el canal está libre? Y
si lo está, ¿cómo sabe un nodo si puede
o no apropiarse de los recursos de la
red?
¿Vale? Puesto que los bit deben ser
agrupados en tramas, ¿cómo confeccionan
esas tramas? Además, ¿cómo saber si las
tramas recibidas son correctas?
¿Vale? Aunque TCPIP no sigue la
arquitectura o sí, se pueden establecer
paralelismos como los que aparecen en
esta figura. Quiero decir, o sea,
vale, la capa transporte tendríamos TCP
y UDP. Ahora veremos lo que es lo que es
todo lo que es todo esto. Ahí nos nos
dice los puertos también.
Se ve un poco. A ver.
TP30. Vale,
no, espera que esto. No.
A ver, espera.
Protocolo IP.
Vale, vamos a aquí el temario y luego y
luego entramos así más en detalle,
¿vale?
El protocolo IP es el protocolo de nivel
de red de Arpanet, el sistema de
comunicaciones que tradicional que
tradicionalmente han utilizado los
sistemas Unix y que nació a principios
de los años 80. Lo más relevante de de
IP para el administrador de red es que
proporciona un sistema de direcciones
para cada nodo de la red queda
identificado por una dirección de cuatro
números enteros separados por puntos. Lo
que estuvimos mirando de
32 bit que está conformado por por
cuatro tetos,
¿vale? Y esto se denomina dirección IP o
de nivel 3 para distinguirla de la
dirección Mac
física o de nivel dos que se compone de
12 dígitos exadecimales.
Vale, el protocolo IP
acepta
acepta bloques de datos procedentes de
la capa de transporte.
Por ejemplo, desde el protocolo TCP que
operan en nivel de transporte.
Vale,
aquí tendríamos, bueno, aquí
esquemático, ¿vale? Sería así un
poquito, ¿vale?
Vale. Procedentes de la cámara de
transporte, por ejemplo, desde el
protocolo TCP que opera el nivel de
transporte de hasta 64
bits.
Aquí lo veis. Cada bloque de datos que
en este nivel se denomina segmentos,
debe ser transferido a través de la red
de en forma de datagramas. Para llevar a
cabo este transporte,
normalmente la capa de red debe
fraccionar los datagramas en un conjunto
de paquetes IP que deben ser asamblados
en el destino para que el mensaje sea al
final reconstruido con fidelidad.
Al ser IP un protocolo sin conexión,
cada paquete puede seguir una ruta, una
ruta distinta a través de internet.
El protocolo de capa superior será el
encargado de la gestión de errores.
Vale, el ICMP, el protocolo ICMP
es eh protocolo de mensaje de control
entre redes. Es un protocolo que expresa
en un único packet de IP algún evento
que se produce en la red.
Por tanto, se trata de un protocolo de
supervisión.
cualquier error,
pero
cualquier eh
cualquier redim debe utilizar el
protocolo ICMP en la dirección
O sea, en esta dirección podemos
encontrar el formato de los paquetes
ICMP, así como detalles del
funcionamiento orgánico del protocolo.
Bueno, vamos a echarle un vistazo.
MP
en castellano. Entiendo que será
Vale, nos dice que el inicia después del
IPV4 cabecera y se entifica con el
protocolo número uno. Todos los paquetes
y CMP táan una cabecera de 8 bits y la
sección de datos de tamaño variable. Los
primeros 4 bytes de la cabecera serán
consistentes. El primer byte es
reservado para el tipo ICMP. El segundo
tetos para el código de ICMP. El tercero
y cuarto es una suma de comprobación de
todo el mensaje ICMP.
Eso en packet traces sí que os prepararé
un ejercicio de y lo haremos, se hará en
clase y lo veremos.
Vale, porque sí que tiene la
implementación esta, me suena.
Entonces ahí posiblemente lo veremos con
más
lo entenderemos un poquito mejor.
Vale, ICMP.
Vale, ahora vamos a hablar de TCP,
el protocolo TCP
que como hemos estado viendo, o sea,
funciona la capa de transporte
fue especialmente diseñado para realizar
conexiones en redes inseguras. TCP es un
un protocolo de capa de transporte
adecuado para proporcionar seguridad a
IP. La seguridad del protocolo TCP la
hace idóneo para la transmisión de datos
por sesiones para aplicar cliente
servidor y para servicios críticos como
el correo electrónico.
La seguridad en TCP tiene un precio que
se manifiesta en forma de grandes
cabeceras de mensajes
y de la necesidad de confirmaciones de
mensajes para asegurar las
comunicaciones. estas confirmaciones que
un tráfico
sobreañadido en la red.
Muy bien. Eh,
gráfico sobre añadido en la red que
ralentiza las transmisiones en beneficio
de la seguridad.
Los puntos de acceso al servicio
SAP de OSI en la capa de transporte CP
se llaman sockets o conectores TCPIP y
son extraordinariamente útiles en la
programación de aplicaciones de red.
Vale, detrás de cada socket activo, sin
planta.
Efectivamente, está en lo cierto, la
herramienta fundamental en la capa de
Esto es el Gémini este, ¿eh? Madre mía,
chaval.
Es un virus.
Le tengo que quitar los permisos a la
bestia porque es que es que es demasiado
el nivel de de intrusión.
Vale, los puntos de acceso al servicio
de la capa de transporte en CPIP se
llaman sok o conectores TCP IP y son
extraordinariamente útiles en la
programación de aplicaciones de red.
Detrás de cada socket activo se implanta
un servicio de red. Cuando alguien en la
red requiere de este servicio, manda
mensajes al socket o puerto que
identifica a este servicio. Algunos
servicios tienen necesidad de más de un
socker para su funcionamiento. Por
ejemplo, 80 es el puerto que que
identifica las peticiones de red hacia
un servidor web.
Vale, el protocolo UDP, ¿vale? Lo
tenemos aquí también.
Aquí junto a a TCP. Vamos a ver en qué
se diferencia de de la capa de, o sea,
del TCP en la capa de transporte,
¿vale?
Es un protocolo de transporte sin
conexión, es decir, permite la
transmisión de mensajes sin necesidad de
establecer ninguna conexión
y, por tanto, sin garantías de entrega.
Actúa
actúa simplemente como una interfaz
entre los procesos de los usuarios de la
red y el protocolo IP. Se utilizan
transmisiones rápidas que no necesitan
seguridad en la transmisión.
UDP no impone el uso de confirmaciones
puestas,
perdón, no impide el uso de
confirmaciones puesto que su objetivo no
es la seguridad y esto hace de él un
protocolo de transporte de mucho mayor
rendimiento que TCP y también más
inseguro. En la tabla 3.1 Uno, se pueden
observar algunas de las características
que diferencia a TCP de UDP,
a pesar de que ambos operan el nivel
cuatro equivalente del modelo ósse o
capa de transporte en el modelo TCPIP.
Eh,
¿vale? Las principales diferencias entre
TCP y UDP. TCP es un protocolo
confiable, UDP no es confiable. TCP está
orientado a la conexión.
UDP no establece una conexión inicial.
TCP lleva gestión de las retransmisiones
y control de flujo.
UDP no gestiona retransmisiones.
TCP secuencia numéricamente los
segmentos
y nos gestiona UDP no gestiona un
secuenciamiento de segmentos. TCP admite
segmentos de acusa de recibo y UDP no
incorpora acusa de recibo.
Vale,
sí que había un ejercicio para el
protocolo RP
en el packet tracer, pero bueno, eso lo
veremos también
que esto lo vamos a ahora haré una serie
de cuestiones y tal y yo creo que nos va
a quedar así un poquito un poquito más
claro con las cuestiones, ¿vale? Después
de
de haber visto esto. Espera a ver, vamos
por aquí.
Vale, aquí como un glosario, ¿no? Eh,
Vale, esto está mejor.
Vale, y luego podemos ir viendo
utilidades también.
Vale,
vale. Pues venga, que no es todo chapa
de de esta o de la mala.
Vale, ARP
no es un protocolo relacionado
directamente con el transporte de datos.
Vale, lo vemos aquí
a mitad de camino
entre red y enlace.
Vale, entonces vamos a ver un poquito
qué es lo que
es lo que nos quiere decir.
Vale, ARP no es un protocolo relacionado
directamente con el transporte de datos,
sino que complementa la acción de TCPIP,
pasando desapercibido a los ojos de los
usuarios y de las aplicaciones de la
red.
Como el protocolo IP equivalente al tres
al perdón al nivel 3 del modelo OSI
utiliza un sistema de direccionamiento
que utiliza el sistema operativo que no
tiene nada que ver con las direcciones
MAC nivel 2 de Osi que utilizan las
tarjetas de las redes de área local. Hay
que arbitrar un mecanismo de asignación
de direcciones IP. Cuatro números
separados. Bueno, o sea, nos está
diciendo lo que es una dirección IP.
Eh, hay que arbitrar un mecanismo de
asignación de direcciones IP a
direcciones MAC propias del nivel del
enlace.
De esto se encarga el protocolo RP que
funciona el siguiente modo.
Cuando un host quiere transmitir un
paquete IP, necesita averiguar la
dirección MAC del host de destino, cuya
dirección es la dirección de destino del
campo dirección de destino del paquete
IP.
Para ello genera un paquete de petición
ARP que difunde por toda la red. todos
los nodos de la red de este paquete y
solo aquel host que que tiene la
dirección IP encapsulada en el paquete
RP contesta con otro paquete ARP de
respuesta con su dirección MAC. De este
modo, el host emisor relaciona dirección
IP y dirección MAC, guardando estos
datos en una tabla residente en memoria
para su uso en transmisiones
posteriores. Es que creo que tenía un
Voy a buscarlo, eh, que es que creo que
tengo un un ejercicio
que
en relación con esto sí que sí que es
interesante.
A ver,
vamos a ver.
A ver si me da tiempo para mañana y lo y
lo podemos
porque es que creo que no existe.
A ver,
¿qué va? No es este,
no es este. Nada, no. Pues si me da
tiempo para como mañana tenemos clase
de
de redes locales, pues lo podemos mirar
también.
No me voy a poner a buscar, pero sí que
es sí que sé que tengo uno por ahí
de a ver relativo a esto. A ver, espera,
lo voy a buscar en la
un segundillo, ¿eh?
A ver.
No, no, no, no.
No lo tengo.
Vale,
vale.
Venga, el direccionamiento de redes
antecipe, ¿vale? Clases de subredes.
Tenemos clase A. Vale, clase B
y clase C. O sea, estábamos diciendo que
estos tres primeros, o sea, que en
Casula. A ver,
transmisión
forma de grandes cabeceras de mensajes.
confirmación para asegurar estas
condiciones de tráfico.
Vale, las máscaras de su red es una
secuencia 32 bit que sirve para
distinguir con facilidad que parte de
una dirección codificada su red,
una subdivisión o grupo de la red total
y qué parte de host.
Eh, bueno, ¿y qué parte y qué parte del
host?
Una máscara se se construye poniendo a
uno los bit. Es que esto lo estuvimos
viendo también el en en mi IPV4,
¿vale? ¿Os acordáis que es eh que la
parte de red estaba escrita con uno y la
parte de host estaba escrita con cero?
Entonces si obviamente si tenemos
en el objeto tenemos estos cuatro unos
que nos suma la las cantidades de todos
estos unos 255,
¿vale? Entonces tendríamos el 255
porque sería la suma de todos estos.
Esto que nos suma ceros,
¿vale? Cer, ¿vale? Y estaríamos en la
subred de clase A.
Y aquí lo mismo, o sea, ya lo estuvimos
viendo, ¿os acordáis que que estuvimos
ahí con la pizarra y se estuvo y se
estuvo presentando todo esto, ¿vale?
Vale, en la tabla 32 se pu ¿Dónde está
la tabla 32? Vale, sería esta de aquí,
¿no?
Vale, en la tabla, la subred de la clase
C tendría la máscara 255 255 2550.
que son posibles combinaciones
cualquiera de los bits para generar
subredes dentro de las subredes dentro
de siempre que tanto los uno como los
cer aparezcan consecutivos. En la tabla
32 se puede observar los significados de
los diferentes códigos
eh
CR.
¿Y cuántos host se pueden identificar en
cada sub? La última columna, máscara
equivalente se refiere a a la máscara
equivalente al ¿Dónde está la
la tabla 32?
Debe ser esta.
Vale, frecuentemente, para facilitar la
anotación suele expresarse la dirección
IP en formato
en formato CIT CR,
que consiste en escribir la dirección IP
en su forma habitual, cuatro números
enteros separados por uno.
Vale, seguida de otro entero,
seguida de otro entero cuyo valor es el
número de uno seguidos de la máscara. O
sea,
cuyo valor es el número de unos seguidos
de la máscara. Estos dos ejemplos deben
ir separados por un símbolo slash, un
ejemplo de notación sería, vale, esto de
aquí,
¿vale? 1 2 8 103 67/24.
¿Qué es? ¿Qué nos indica el 24? El
número de bit ocupados por unos. O sea,
que tendríamos 20
tendríamos
241 frente a 80,
¿vale? Significa pues eso, que la
máscara
la máscara de red sería 255 255 255.0
241 seguidos de otros 80 ceros.
Lo que vale lo que significa que
pertenece a la a la red 128 100 3.0,
o sea, el cer inicial.
Vale. ¿Y cuántos hasta cuántos podríamos
cuántos cuántos host podríamos podríamos
poner en esta red?
Vale, contamos con que el último se
utiliza para envío de paquetes y el
primero
y el primero no se asigna a ningún a
ningún host, o sea, sería el
tendríamos desde el 1 hasta el 254,
¿vale?
pues teníamos realmente 250
254 direcciones que, o sea, 250
direcciones diferentes que podríamos que
podríamos implementar en esa en esa red.
Esto nos ayuda a eh a escalar
dependiendo de lo que queramos de lo o
sea escalar la red en función de lo que
queramos implementar.
Obviamente para una vivienda pues pues
con una con una red de estas nos va a ir
de perlas, pero si nos vamos a una
oficina con mogollón de dispositivos
como podría ser el instituto este, pues
a lo mejor ahí se nos queda corta,
a no ser de que lo dividamos en
diferentes subredes,
¿vale? Protocolos TCIP de nivel
superior. En el nivel superior de la
arquitectura TCIP hay una infinidad de
protocolos
que aquí vamos a referir a los más
comunes, pero existen casi tantos
protocolos distintos como tipos de
aplicaciones
o servicios de nivel de aplicación.
FTP es utilizado para descarga o carga
de ficheros en internet.
Define dos canales de comunicación, uno
para el gobierno de esta y otro para la
transferencia de datos. Pone en marcha
el diálogo entre un cliente FTP y un
servidor FTP. ¿Sabéis lo que es FTP? ¿Lo
habéis usado alguna vez?
No,
no. Vale, pues quieres que que le
echemos un vistazo
Sí, tú quieres. Vale,
venga.
Vale, pues vamos a vamos a ver lo que es
un FTP. Es que vale, lo podemos ver con
Packet Tracer. Sí, vamos a verlo con
Packet Tracer o lo podíamos ver con una
con una máquina virtual. A ver.
Y el cliente cliente servidor filecilla.
Aquí no lo puedo hacer
porque tengo caducado el el certificado
y aquí no me deja.
A ver si me deja abrir la máquina.
¿Dónde lo tengo?
Vale, yo lo tengo aquí.
Vale, abrimos.
Abro Windows Server porque
creo que no me va a dejar abrir el
cliente este porque me suena que lo
tengo aquí
el filecill ya lo digo por no instalarlo
otra vez en otra máquina porque a nivel
de a nivel de máquina local a mí no me
deja.
Entonces, bueno, pues eso.
[Música]
Pues sí que a ver si me deja. Vale,
entonces no va a hacer falta.
Vale, genial. No va a hacer falta. Vale,
pues cierro cierro Windows Server.
Instalado en modo
A ver que que inicie y lo cierro.
Bueno, para empezar a a familiarizarnos
un poquito, por ejemplo, Windows Server
lo podemos lo podemos instalar en modo
gráfico o funcionar con él en modo Power
Cell.
No sé si habéis tocado algo de de
Windows Server
alguna vez.
Nada.
Vale, vale, ya tendremos tiempo.
A ver,
pasa esta. A ver,
vale, ahora sí.
Vale, le decimos.
Entonces nos vamos a este,
¿vale? Y tenemos filecilla
server,
¿vale? que esto no es más, imaginaos
quecilla server lo tenemos instalado en
en una máquina servidor, por ejemplo, y
el cliente lo tenemos en cliente. Aquí
en este caso lo vamos a tener tanto
tanto el server como el cliente lo vamos
a tener en la misma máquina,
¿vale? Entonces, veis el host, el el
local host como estamos en
está configurado para eso,
¿vale? Para que Vale, entonces abriría
el server. Configuramos.
Aquí tengo usuarios.
A ver, tengo usuarios creados a user
uno, que vete a saber qué contraseña le
puse, pero bueno, yo voy a intentarlo.
Vale, entonces lo que vamos a lo que
vamos a hacer es
acceder a las a las diferentes carpetas
en función de nuestros de nuestros
permisos. A ver, no no vamos a entrar
tan profundamente en eso, o sea,
simplemente
que sepamos que tenemos un user, un
user, ¿vale? Y ahora nos esto sería el
server al que le hemos dado una serie de
privilegios. En este caso serían de
en este caso serían de escritura de
lectura, además de crear directorios
cuando no si estos no existen.
Vale, aquí lo podemos lo podemos poner
de soldado raso, o sea, lee solo, ¿vale?
No escribes nada y no puedes y no puedes
generar ningún ningún directorio ni
puedes generar nada.
Vale, entonces eh
nos venimos a cliente,
¿vale? Y aquí nos vamos a conectar al
server, que sería el 127
punto0
punto
0.1, Uno, si no recuerdo mal,
creo que es que lo hemos puesto esto, un
user
a secas y contraseña. Voy a probar un 2
3 cuale,
me está diciendo que el certificado eh
pues examine, vale, pero no me da error
de certificado.
Me dice que es desconocido, pero pero se
lo traga. Vale, entonces,
vale, entonces me ha listado el
directorio al que tengo acceso, que
sería
todos estos de aquí. ¿Para qué sirve
esto?
para que nosotros podamos subir y bajar
ficheros, o sea, archivos
principalmente. No sé si habéis entrado
alguna vez a una página de de descarga
de de repositorios de Linux o
sabes que te lista un montón de de
ficheros que dices, ostras, ¿y esto qué
es? Y que tiene así como una estructura
de carpeta o de directorio. Pues eso es
que habéis entrado en un servidor FTP.
Vale, entonces a ver esta como está
dentro de este mismo equipo, está punta
aquí a en C,
¿vale? Sería esta carpeta de aquí. Si yo
en esta carpeta nuevo directorio le
digo, "A ver, vamos a
voy a abrir el cliente en la última de
todos de todo." Ficheros dos 2 2 ostras,
sí que tengo ahí 3 tr. Vale, pues ahora
voy a Este es el último. Ya. Pues ahora
voy a crear a ver si me deja
nuevo. Ficheros 2 2 3 3 3. ¿Veis que no?
Después de 333 ya no hay nada. Pero si
yo vengo aquí y le digo nuevo crear
carpeta
inmediatamente
inmediatamente no. Cuando aquí actualice
ya tenemos la 444 creada. Vale, esto,
imaginaos que este servidor está en
Oklahoma y tú estás en las petroñeras,
pues te va perfecto.
No hace falta esos extremos, pero bueno,
o sea, se entiende, ¿no? Que
para para
envío y para transferencia de archivos
FTP es lo es lo que toca.
Luego ya podemos entrar en más en más
temas de seguridad y tal, entonces ya
implementaríamos más
más tipos de protocolos dentro de este
de este FTP,
¿vale? Igual que aquí si le decimos, a
ver, crear directorio, aquí vamos a
crear el 55.
Aceptar. Vale, hemos quedado el 55, no
estaba y nos venimos aquí y dentro está
el 55.
Vale, pues eso sería el FTP,
básicamente, intercambio de ficheros.
Ho.
[Música]
Vale, htp es, bueno, nos ha faltado
verlo en en
Packet Tracer, que también tiene también
podemos generar un servidor de
A ver si aquí añadimos un server.
Podríamos ponerlo. Pero
teníamos que eh ¿por qué por qué he
hecho esto? O sea, porque realmente
estamos entre dos equipos, ¿vale? Por
mucho server que sea, aquí, ¿qué
deberíamos de poner entre medias?
Deberíamos de poner un switch, o sea, se
supone que vamos a a implementar más
equipos. Ya no, aunque no sean equipos.
Una impresora, por ejemplo, ya no
podríamos. O sea, si aquí solo
disponemos de un puerto.
A ver,
ponemos
esto. Me lo cargo.
Vale,
vale. Este lo tenemos aquí,
¿vale? Pues aquí, si os fijáis
servicios tenemos el FTP activado,
¿vale? Aquí le podemos decir, eh,
bueno, para empezar vamos a activar hcp.
Bueno, no lo ponemos en en dirección.
A este lo vamos a llamar 192.168.
es 8 pun
0 pun
máscara de su
y al
a este
20,
¿vale? Máscara su red la misma. Entonces
nos lo va a detectar que está en la
misma red. Bueno, el tema es
esto habíamos dicho que era 1680.
Este es 168020.
Vale. Eh, aquí activamos,
nos venimos a FTP
y le decimos que pues vamos a crear uno,
uno que se llame eh
user user
y contraseña
pues 1 2 3 cu
así fácil.
Le damos al user
permiso de escritura, de lectura, de
borrado, de renumbrar y de listar.
¿Vale? ¿Veis? Todos estos permisos son
los no son más que la
la primera
la primera letra de cada palabra, ¿vale?
Entonces está aquí tendríamos
exactamente los mismos.
¿Vale? ¿Qué podemos listar aquí? Pues
todos estos
esto sería, digamos, lo que lo que
contiene este servidor FTP, ¿vale? Son,
a ver, obviamente esto es de ejemplo, es
que no vamos a tener aquí grandes cosas,
¿vale? Pero como o sea, da cuenta, le
hemos le hemos dado todos los permisos,
¿vale? Entonces nos venimos
aquí al
Bueno, para empezar le hacemos un pin.
Vale, le hacemos un pin
al server desde el desde el PC 192.168.
punto
0.10, ¿verdad? Era 0.10.
Vale, entonces sí que se comunica. Vale,
entonces ahora, ¿qué es lo que qué es lo
que tenemos que hacer? Vale, nos venimos
aquí a esto. No, es que no quiero esto.
A ver. Vale,
vale. Nos venimos aquí.
a la consola y le decimos FTP.
Creo que era así. Creo que no había que
implementar aquí nada más.
FTP19.168.0.10.
[Música]
Vale, ahora me está pidiendo, veis que
me está pidiendo el nombre de usuario,
que sería user
y la contraseña, que sería 1 2 3 4.
Vale, por vale, estoy dentro. Vale,
entonces ahora ya como estamos dentro de
la del servidor de FTP, vamos a listar
con el GI.
Ya podemos listar. Y ahora le podemos
decir que me renombre este primer
archivo por
renome.
Eh,
¿cómo es? Es que lo veo demasiado
pequeño. ASA
gu
o un CER es un 8. K8
punto bin por me lo invento
punto ex por ejemplo un
bueno voy a poner a a me lo invento para
que aparezca y no lo tengamos que
buscar.
A a gu baj me lo invento.
Punto bueno punto bueno sí punto s va.
¿Por qué no le decimos intro? Vale, se
va.
me dice que que no tiene permiso, pero
sí que sí que tendría permiso,
eh, posiblemente. A ver,
se asa
asa. Es que es un ocho.
842-k.
K8.bin. A ver si me deja ahora.
Vale, me da el mismo error. No, pero si
lo he cambiado. Ah, no, ahora está bien,
¿no? Eh,
vale. Hay que venir aquí con él.
Verí.
Ah, lo mismo.
No sé. que es es que es rename. Pues
vamos a hacer un
vamos a crear un directorio
a a A
vado
puesto mh dir
sería MK porque yo user sí que tiene los
permisos.
Vale, pues no me deja hoy hacer res.
Vale, sé que sé que está conectado.
Vamos a ver qué ha pasado.
Vale, si nos venimos aquí, aquí no habrá
tocado nada,
¿no?
Vamos a quitar este.
Este tiene todos los permisos. está
activado como no ser de que esté
haciendo. A ver,
no, no me deja por algo. Posiblemente lo
esté poniendo mal,
pero bueno.
Bueno, eso, que sepáis que te puedes
conectar y eso, que esto ya es un tema
de de síntasis.
Vale, pero que sí que tiene hasta todos
los permisos y funcionaría. Bueno, lo
hemos estado viendo con filecilla, así
que funcionaba.
Aquí a nivel consola, pues igual me
falta implementar cualquier
cualquier texto o cualquier cosa.
Vale, le le echaré un vistacillo esto,
eh.
Vale, a ver.
Vale, estamos nos hemos quedado aquí.
Bueno, HTP es el protocolo utilizado por
los navegadores para este sí que lo
conocéis todos, ¿no? El HTTP.
Ese sí,
ese es ese es famosillo.
Cuando es https,
¿qué qué significaría, Jorge?
Pues no tengo ni idea.
Implementación de seguridad,
o sea, que a poder ser no nos metemos en
páginas que solo sea http o qué.
Bueno, a ver, generalmente pues no
no has pagado tanto, ¿no? Con las HTTP,
no lleva implementada esa seguridad
extra, que sería unos certificados de
ahí hay hay para perderse ya en ese en
ese mundo, pero sí sería eso
básicamente. Pero vamos, una página a
ver si entramos en cualquier página.
Vamos a, no sé,
esta de aquí, esta que sería
Linux, eh, vale, esta que estábamos
viendo.
Claro, este no nos va a presentar el
http.
dos puntos.
Vamos a ver una busca. Es que claro,
como están bastante enmascaradas las
webs,
date de tu cuenta,
copiar enlace limpio.
Eh, vale, esta, por ejemplo, copiar
enlace limpio. Si ponemos aquí
pegar, sigue, ves que sí que lleva la S.
Ahora si nos vamos a una de pues yo que
sé, es que pues de una empresilla de
barrio o algo así que se supone que no
se ha no se ha gastado los cuartos a lo
bestia, no sé, no se me ocurre ahora eh
qué ejemplo poner aquí, pero hacer la
prueba, o sea, es que lo vais a ver que
que
en el momento que
ves todas absolutamente
La mayoría de
tienen los tienen el protocolo
implementado, son certificados que que
pagas al final.
Bueno, si queréis lo dejamos aquí esta y
nos ponemos con
nos ponemos con ahora venía
sistemas, ¿no?
Sí. Vale,
vale. Voy a ponerle una marquita a esto.
Oy, ¿qué es? Eh, 13.
Y sí que os tengo preparado un
cuestionario para que miremos todo esto
que hemos estado siguiendo. Y bueno,
luego el tema este de utilidades también
que esto está bien, ¿sabes? Porque
veremos lo que es cada cosa,
¿vale? Son cosas que sí que vamos a ir
utilizando a lo largo de los días.
Vale, pues vamos a lo otro. Vale, esto
que sea guardar los cambios. Espera, me
voy a Quiero que se guarde donde tengo
la marca que si no lo voy perdido.
Vale, ahí.
Vale, pues a ver, apago. No.